let's join Michael wolf a journalist
author of fire and the Fury the story of
Donald Trump's first nine months in the
white house he joins me live from
outside the courthouse in New York
thanks for being with us Michael well it
it seems to be a circus in New York
Trump is the main act and I imagine he's
pretty happy with that
I I don't think he can be happier at
this point I mean in effect this
indictment has returned him from from
what a lot of people thought was the the
margins of politics to the center of it
um I know that a lot of people within
his Circle believe that last Thursday
when he was indicted that was the day
that gave him the Republican nomination
so uh we're we're you know while while
many people are looking at this
indictment
um and thinking Donald Trump has finally
been held accountable
the the people inside his Circle are
looking at this and saying well this
indictment is um
has has changed the political landscape
overwhelmingly changed the political
landscape in his favor
but it is humiliating for Donald Trump
the first American President to face
criminal charges and Donald Trump is not
a man I think that that's I I let me let
me interrupt you I think that's
completely wrong it is not humiliation
does not cross Donald Trump's mind
remember this is a man who has been
impeached twice
um so I I would I would in terms of
trying to understand that the most
important thing is not to credit Donald
Trump with the feelings other normal
people would have because he doesn't
have them well that's very interesting
but I was thinking of a you know Donald
Trump the president in the White House
one moment and now being dragged through
this court process as a common criminal
and you're saying he wouldn't be
humiliated but again yeah
no no
no Donald Trump the president it is done
Trump in every in at every moment it is
him the important thing for him is to
continue to be Donald Trump in that I
would Define that as being the guy at
the center of attention so this once
again and whether that's the the White
House is the center of attention or
um or the the circus outside of a
courtroom is the center of attention it
doesn't matter
he is still he is Donald Trump the
world's eyes are on him and that's the
thing that he wants
I mean there are two ways of looking at
it Michael the first way is that it
suits him politically as you appear to
be suggesting it puts him back front and
center he can play the victim which he
which he likes the other way of looking
at it is that it suits the Democrats
because he is their preferred opponent
maybe the Democrats really think he is
their preferred opponent
I I'm sure both of those things are
exactly true yes
um but
um let me just caution the Democrats
that if he gets the the Republican
nomination you know then it's he could
very well become the president of the
United States that's you know Joe Biden
may be stronger at this point but nobody
knows what's going to happen
presidential races are often decided by
exogenous events we don't know so we are
on a very
um slippery slope here
um to once again the prospect the the
very real prospect that Donald Trump
might become the president
you think that is a a real prospect that
he could not only
win the primary but he'd go on and win
the White House again you think that is
a
a real prospect there well if you ask
yeah well what we're seeing right now is
a very real Prospect of him getting the
Republican nomination I would say
uh that the chances of him winning the
presidency are are if not uh are are
much less than than Joe Biden's chances
but again once when there are only two
people you you don't know lots of things
can happen so as soon as he gets the
Republican nomination yes he is a very
real Contender for uh the White House
once again
Michael I read your book and you've been
inside the White House with Trump's team
when he was president inside Mar-A-Lago
what do you think he'll be thinking now
what will he be doing now what will be
his sort of manner with his team as he
prepares to
to go to court today
I I think he's very well it will be
determined it will be even enthusiastic
um this is all uh this is all going his
way at this point
um he will be on the he will be on the
phone with with supporters and elected
officials who are telling him that he's
the greatest thing in the world
um and he will be on the phone with his
lawyers seeking assurances that um uh
that he won't be uh that that he won't
be convicted that this will likely be
thrown out that um that he is in no
danger and by the way his lawyers will
be giving him
those assurances because if you're
Donald Trump's lawyers what you know is
to tell him what he wants to hear
um so all in all Donald Trump right now
this is a very good day for him